if the US and North Korea had a Facebook
page each country would change their
status to it's complicated now it's not
what we had as recently as 2017 when
Trump was threatening to go to war over
and over again with North Korea they
will be met with fire and fury like the
world has never seen
hit Don Shula Nazca music's only
handsome good now they're not only on
speaking terms but literally sitting in
a room with each other chairman Kim and
I just signed a joint statement in which
he reaffirmed his unwavering commitment
to complete denuclearization the problem
with this is that Trump and North Korea
have very different views about what
should be accomplished when you
denuclearize the Korean Peninsula
[Music]
the US wants North Korea to give up its
nuclear weapons North Korea wants the
United States to stop isolating and
diplomatically and stop cutting it off
from international markets in theory
there's the makings of a deal there for
Trump denuclearization means something
called CVID complete verifiable
irreversible denuclearization of North
Korea they give up their nuclear weapons
and the US will always be able to make
sure that they have gone away
however for North Korea denuclearization
of the Korean Peninsula mean something
completely different
it means sure North Korea gets rid of
its nukes but the u.s. also withdraws
all its troops from the Korean Peninsula
and ends its alliance with South Korea
this has been unacceptable to every
American president in the past we will
be stopping the war games which will
save us a tremendous amount of money
unless and until we see that the future
negotiation is not going along like it
should what seems really good for North
Korea is really bad by American
standards there's just not a great
middle ground that could actually roll
back North Korea's nuclear program
no country with a nuclear program as
advanced as North Korea's has ever
denuclearized a 2017 estimate from the
Defense Intelligence Agency concluded
the North Korea probably has up to 60
nuclear weapons
it also has ballistic missiles that
could potentially hit the American
homeland and potentially a nuclear
weapon small enough to fit on one of
those Rockets national security advisor
John Bolton floated an idea for dealing
with North Korea that he called the
Libya model so this is to reference an
agreement struck with the Bush
administration by then Libyan dictator
Muammar Qaddafi to give up his nuclear
program however Gaddafi's program was
way more limited he wasn't really even
close to a bomb and perhaps more to the
point about eight years after this
agreement was struck in 2011 the u.s.
backed an uprising against Qaddafi which
killed him - Kim Libya is an example of
what happens if you trust the United
States too much it's an example of what
happens if you give up your nuclear
weapons it's the main reason they want
them is to deter an attack
ideally they want to deter any war from
starting by making the war seen
really scary and really dangerous and
really bloody normalizing relations is
something that I would expect to do I
would hope to do when everything's
complete normalization is a prize from
North Korea's point of view it would
mean a u.s. embassy in Pyongyang and
North Korean embassy in Washington
ambassador's formal diplomatic
receptions and like I'm saying this and
you're probably imagining that sounds
ridiculous and you're right
because it's North Korea unwavering
commitment to the complete
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
this is the document that we just said
it's hard to imagine the endgame being
some kind of big big deal what's more
likely is that nothing changes or things
get worse again I think he's gonna do
these things I may be wrong I mean I may
stand before you in six months and say
hey I was wrong I don't know that I'll
ever admit that but I'll find us I'll
find some kind of an excuse